Speaker 1: No shirt.
No shoes, no vaccine, no service.
OK, that is legally something that businesses
can say in the same way that you can have
requirements for going into a business that
might include you've got to be wearing shoes
or you've got to be wearing a shirt for public
health purposes, for sanitation purposes.
Business is going to say you've got to be
vaccinated against covid-19.
We've seen the start in other countries and
we're now seeing it start in the United States.
Restaurants tell customers no vaccine, no
service as Delta variant spreads.
This is an interesting article from MarketWatch
as covid cases increase.
Establishments are requiring customers to
prove they are fully vaccinated and they're
running into protests in the process.
Not surprisingly, as covid-19 cases surged
through the U.S., a growing number of dining
and drinking establishments are turning unvaccinated
customers away, saying their businesses can't
risk possibly exposing patrons and staff to
the virus.
But these Novavax no service decisions have
sparked controversy with anti vaccination
groups and individuals saying they constitute
a violation of civil rights.
Some states, such as Florida and Texas, have
enacted laws that essentially prevent private
businesses from imposing these bans on the
unvaccinated.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about,
despite what Republican Trumpy and Gov. Rhonda
Santurce has done in Florida trying to ban
any such vaccine requirements, mayors all
over Florida in different parts of Florida
are defying Ron Ron DeSantis and saying, no,
let's do the vaccine requirements.
Let's allow the vaccine requirements.
Anyway, we'll talk about that on today's bonus
show.
The bars and restaurants putting the vaccine
requirements in place range from individually
owned ones to small chains.
In San Francisco, a local bar owner organization
representing more than 300 establishments
announced Monday its calling for bar customers
to show proof of vaccination or a negative
covid test to enter bars.
Italy has started doing this.
Parts of Spain are going to be doing this.
France, I'm sorry, France, not Italy.
Italy maybe is going to do it.
I'm not actually sure.
On Italy, patrons who don't meet the requirement
will be allowed to sit outside at local drinking
spots.
Ben Blakeman, president of the San Francisco
Bar Owner Alliance and a bar proprietor himself,
said it is hard to ignore the fact that covid-19
can easily be spread by unvaccinated individuals.
So at a time when there is a dramatic rise
in cases, the ban is simply necessary.
It seems to be the easiest and fastest way
to protect people, he said.
City Winery, a national bar and restaurant
chain that offers live music by prominent
artists.
Actually, our friend Matisyahu is soon going
to be playing some city winery gigs in New
York and I believe in Boston.
City Winery already had a vaccine requirement
in place for its New York City location.
After serving customers throughout the country
over the last few days by email, it is decided
to extend the requirement at all its establishments
starting next week.
More than 75 percent of customers who responded
to the survey supported the vaccine requirement.
He also said that when he is at his New York
City venue and talks to those on hand before
a performance, he gets a standing ovation.
This is going to be the new battle.
And we are later, I'm going to show you it's
going to look like it's a five year old.
It's actually a full grown adult.
Going on a complete tantrum about masks on
the floor of the House of Representatives,
we are going to see a certain contingent of
the American population go absolutely cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs based on here we go now businesses
not regulated in this way by the government.
In other words, the government is not regulated.
Some states are trying to, but the government
is not regulating businesses in so far as
telling them you must or you cannot or whatever
put in place a vaccine requirement.
Businesses are deciding for themselves the
way Republicans claim they want businesses
to be able to do.
Hey, are we better off overall with a vaccine
requirement to come to our establishment or
not?
And if people see the vaccine requirement
and they say that's terrible, sir, we hate
it, then they can choose not to go to that
establishment.
The business is able to make the decision
they believe is best for them.
They may be right.
They may be wrong, but it's their right to
make that decision.
And then you as a consumer can say, I want
to reward this business with my money, voting
with my dollars because I like their rule
or I am going to avoid this business.
You might choose to avoid a business because
they do have a vaccine requirement.
they do not have a vaccine requirement.
And either way, everybody is making the choice
that is best for them.
You don't have a right to go unvaccinated
to a private restaurant.
It will be up to you to figure out where you
want to go.
Now, that's that's the libertarian small government,
you know, argument for what is going on.
I have a sense that so-called small government
conservatives are not going to take it the
way that I am laying it out.
They are going to say it's a violation of
the Constitution.
It's a violation of Hypatia, hippo, rhino,
elephant, giraffe, whatever.
Right.
They'll they'll come up with what?
It's a violation.
I've I've been violated and it is going to
be the latest.
Seventy to ninety six hour scandal on right
wing media.
That's the expectation.
I assume by Monday we're going to start to
see it.
Speaking of important Mondays, by the way,
we are now one to, I guess, three Mondays
away from the sixteenth anniversary of The
David Pakman Show, also known as the sixteen
year wait.
No, sixteen year anniversary is that's that's
an oxymoron, right?
Sixteen year anniversary.
It's the sixteenth anniversary that I'm sure
of.
It will be Monday, August 16th.
We are doing a one day membership special.
We're calling it a membership bomb, but it's
a bomb only in the best sense.
There's nothing violent of any kind.
And if you're interested in signing up at
an extreme discount to celebrate this sixteen
year anniversary, please sign up for my newsletter
at David Pakman dot com.
And then Monday, August 16th, you'll be notified.
Hey, here is how you sign up and take advantage
of the discount.
All right, we just have too much to get to
today for me to spend the next 20 minutes
talking about membership so I won't.
I hope people will accept my apology.
And people I'm sure we're looking forward
to that.